Let's go next to our caller from the five,
seven one area code.
Who's calling today from five, seven one.
Hey David, this is Mark calling from Virginia.
Hey Mark, what's up?
I had a question about the reason Hillary
Spears against Bernie Sanders.
Yes.
Okay.
So I was wondering if there would be like,
um, backlash response from Bernie supporters.
In what sense?
What would they do as far as a backlash?
I mean, Hillary is not on the ballot.
Well in the sense that it would energize and
galvanize the Bernie base.
So similar thing with Trump, right?
Where the media smears actually worked in
his favor.
Do you think a similar thing would happen
with progressive?
It's conceivable.
But here's the thing.
Um, at this point, all of these things that
just muddle up the progressive side of the
primary, they just help Biden like, okay,
so there's a backlash and the Bernie supporters
are, are re-invigorated unless Bernie can
take the lead and start winning primary soon,
cause we're only two weeks away from the first
primaries.
All of this stuff just keeps Biden and quietly
in the lead.
He'll start to win primaries and accumulate
delegates.
So yes, there could be a backlash, but it's
got to happen now.
Well, do you think that the reason
Mark, you've gone completely underwater, so
I'm going to let you go.
Something about your connection is, is abhorrent
and I don't know if it's device based or signal
based or a or or whatever the case may be.
Let's see if we can talk to our caller from
the nine one, two area code color from nine
one two.
Who's this and what's your question today?
Hi Jonathan.
Also from Georgia.
Other torture callers.
Yeah.
Uh, I'm a big Andrew Yang fan and I know you've
covered gang throughout this whole gang media
blackout that's been going on recently.
Uh, my question is your stance or opinion
on his idea of taxing automation to fund the
freedom dividend.
Do you think that that's going to hold back
or in any way interfere with the automation
way that he thinks going to have to, he thinks
it's going to happen.
Well, so a couple of things.
Number one, is there a yang media blackout?
I know he wasn't at the debate, but I'm seeing
him everywhere.
It's like he's on a, he's on network television.
He's on cable television.
He's on the view.
His wife is doing all sorts of interviews.
I don't know that there is a yang media blackout.
I think he just didn't make the last debate.
I think before the debate.
I think the big thing, the debate not being
there really gave him a lot of push with the
media.
I feel like that's gotten him a few more calls
because it was a big deal of him when the
polling and, and not being able to make the
stage even though other people who I believe
poll less but somehow still got up there.
Um, but I feel like it's gotten him a lot
more media attention now.
But for a while there was a good bit of me
a black, I guess it is raising a little bit.
I am seeing a little bit, few, few more interviews
he's doing and more appearances on media.
But I feel like for awhile there was a blackout,
but I guess you could say yes, that's slowly
lifting as his, his wife is now going on places
and so is he on, you know, networks.
So here's my answer to the question about
taxing automation.
Here's the thing.
So if we think back to when cars came into
development and people started saying, Hey,
we've got to slow down this car stuff because
the horse buggy drivers and the farriers and
everybody who works around horses are going
to lose their jobs.
It seems crazy to think that just taxing cars
back then would have prevented cars from being
developed.
And it also seems crazy to think we would
have wanted that because of course cars have
completely revolutionized how humans operate.
So I don't think that you are going to be
able to use a tax to prevent automation from
appearing more and more in places where it's
going to appear.
I think eventually it's going to happen in
places that are going to benefit companies
and industries that will benefit from automation
and it remember automation will also benefit
safety in many cases.
It'll benefit few minutes.
Human health.
There's lots of ways in which automation will
be good.
I don't think you're gonna hold it back with
attacks.
However, I am not against in the short to
medium term using that tax to fund retraining
and development of new industries in areas
where machines can't do the work.
Okay, so you don't think a freedom dividends.
The best answer you think training is cause
I know he's talked a lot about that.
The freedom dividend is a own question.
I'm fine talking.
I'm, I'm a universal basic income is a great
idea and I'm fine talking about it.
I just don't know that I have a super strong
position on, I would use an automation tax
to fund the freedom dividend.
You can fund the freedom dividend a whole
bunch of different ways.
I'm not super married to one way or the other,
but I am interested in the idea of taxing
to prevent automation from taking hold.
I don't think longterm that's going to work.
All right.
Thank you.
All right, appreciate the phone call so much.
Sorry,
I don't have time for more people, but we
will take calls on the Friday show.
We will take a quick break and be back with
plenty more.
Right after this